preacher Abba or whatever the reach
reach yeah reach is really reaching like
like
they're just pandering to their fans who
don't like me because I'm fat you know
yeah that's the whole Market thing
that's the whole one he got us he got us
our marketing is the Pander to defense
that they'll like it because
Ethan you're saying that because you're
insecure
it's just funny to me now we've been
depends that don't like you because
you're fat and 95 of our fans think I am
by the way on Abba and preach you
cowards you losers when you make a video
about this which I know you will
entitled Ethan client's mad or whatever
include this
a link to the full interview and
encourage your audience to go watch that
full interview we got you recently we're
going to put the link in the description
below you guys know and the title of
this video will be Ethan is bad go tell
them go watch that full interview where
Ethan's so embarrassing and then come
back and tell me how embarrassing Ethan
is because I and we'll play this whole
thing or you're just the biggest coward
in the world make sure you reply to the
video we did about your doxing and you
uh falsely accusing friendship fit make
sure you do reply to that too I am sure
that if any one of your fans watched
that whole interview they will realize
what a disingenuous piece of [__] you're
being right now okay he doesn't think
that you are women significant others
should post themselves with like
cleavage and stuff
listen listen okay I'm gonna make this
super abundantly clear so that there's
no more misunderstandings
that you want to post online I just said
that for some people in their
relationships they don't want a partner
who's posting thirst traps they don't
want a partner who's on social media
attention [__] and that's a very
reasonable thing to not want in
relationship that is it it is fine if
you want that in your relationship and
you're fine with it and you find it
empowering
Genesis for this was he put out a video
on Tick Tock like uh something about
like how women should dress
yeah
what no no no no no stop
stop I'll play the original Tick Tock
that's what I said he said if I'm with a
girl he didn't tell other people how
they have to dress he didn't tell women
what they have to do every day he's not
telling everyone get an open
relationship he's saying I like open
relationships I want to run my open
relationship this way which is okay you
listen this is so stupid the way two
people want to legislate their
relationship and the boundaries within
them is between the two people even when
they're with me I wouldn't want them to
do that in public okay
okay
what's the problem well it just it's a
little insecure listen people know dude
let's see what they say but based off
the kind of things that they wear
they're going to get a different
reception from people yeah if I'm with a
woman yeah and she's out here dressed
like she's going to Cancun tomorrow I'm
gonna feel a little bit like that [__]
is off not because it makes me like
you're 100 insecure then yeah you can't
handle it dude
you're [__] out at yourself
completely sorry it does
the things that they wear they're going
to get a different reception from people
yeah farmer with a woman and she's out
here dressed like she's going to Cancun
tomorrow I'm gonna feel a little bit
like that she is off yeah yep that's
your problem
look it's your preference if you don't
want to be with a girl who's comfortable
doing that right but the but the
underlying emotion which was try I was
trying to coax out with Sebastian is
that what is that feeling of feeling off
it's disgust
I think it's disgusting when someone
wants to be that trashy looking
does it
say well I think it's [__] disgusting
when I see dudes sag their pants and
have they boxers hanging out the ass
cheeks can I not be disgusted by
something it has to be in security can I
not find something unsightly why is it
always insecurity that's the question
can't be any other motivation anyways
crazy how Liberals are the most like
illiberal when it comes to any other
perspective
the open-minded people are the most
closed-minded they can't understand I
can understand their perspective they
want to be able to wear whatever it may
be makes them feel empowered Kudos they
can't understand anybody else's they
can't imagine that anyone does anything
different to them other than insecurity
if she wanted to post a picture and I
said look I don't I'm not comfortable I
don't like it and she did it anyway
that's fine she can do it anyway and
then we I would be like hey this is the
way they cut this is insane they just
make it look like I'm bullying him he's
like listen I it's just my opinion it's
just my preference and I'm like whoa you
know
that's crazy you're insecure it's fun
these guys are pieces of [__] the way we
cut this okay this video that I'm
watching isn't something I remove the
context from
this is on the H3 podcast what does it
say
alpha male things illa Hill addresses
like a hoe Hey listen I had to click on
it I love me some hoes so I've seen 14
minutes and I clicked on it I didn't
choose this clip I didn't make it you
did I didn't clip you or contextualize
you differently that's you his point was
that women should not do this and so I'm
probing his logical fallacies that's
literally not what he said at one point
you even asked him is what my wife he's
like if that's your wife that's your
relationship do what you want he says
that in the video but do you I don't
know why she's posting I mean that's
that's you and your wife your
relationship that's you and your wife
your relationship
I wouldn't want my girlfriend posting
pictures okay when you're with me but if
you're not with me you need to not look
pretty that's not what he said I like
that well let's [__] clarify dude let
him answer we're working out
we're having a long conversation dude we
we come to an understanding of what I
mean no you have it no you're still
saying that you have the whole interview
and you're still thing that [__] now
you're still talking about pretty your
wife is still talking about pretty he
did say that though he said
don't dress like that if you're not
going out with me I say pretty in the
sense that like that I think that
like I sh whatever let's just see what
they say I mean watch it's complaining
looking pretty with dressing
provocatively there's plenty of women
who look very pretty and don't dress
incredibly provocatively you can look
pretty in a dress okay it was awesome
yeah no [__] we know all of that okay
say all that because it's not this time
no no no no no no not cheese
don't then say all then say that because
when you say other words that's not what
they mean yeah okay if he said
provocative stiff we're probably oh that
were pretty oh that's what we meant no
if you're having an argument with
someone okay and you're not using the
same definitions of the same words
you can't even argue yeah the problem is
when you conflate those two words they
mean things that are very distinctly
different and and when it sounds like
you're saying oh you don't want your
girl to look pretty it almost makes it
sound like yo we want her in [__]
burkas so they can walk around covering
all the time like no that's not what
you're saying you just say I don't want
her to be provocative it's not the same
thing the words evoke complete different
reactions so that's why we're trying to
say there's complete
different intentions in those words yeah
if someone said I don't want my girl to
ever go out looking good I'm like God
damn that's like three yo you're right
you want this girl looking raggedy every
time she leaves the home like [__]
chill we established earlier in this
conversation I think that women dress
nice to so that and look nice and
sometimes what he thinks is too sexy to
feel good about themselves it's not
about trying to appeal to other men
wrong my stance is you shouldn't dress
provocatively unless you're with me
what's provocative and this is what
we're talking about his his this is what
we're talking about you didn't say
provocative is pretty or not or whatever
it's because he's saying specifically
you cannot dress provocatively if you're
not with me and that is controlling and
that is going back a thousand years
right if she wanted to post a picture
and I said look I don't I'm not
comfortable I don't like it and she did
it anyway that's fine she can do it
anyway and then we I would just be like
hey this breaks the boundary of the
relationship this breaks the the
sanctity of the intimate relationship I
want to have with my wife right um I'm
gonna just split here I'm gonna go find
a girl that respects me it's not about
insecurity it's just this is my
preference this is how I want to conduct
my life and that is controlling and that
is
going back a thousand years I don't want
to control you I just don't want to be
involved with you you're so controlling
I don't want to be involved with you no
you're so controlling it's like no I
just don't want to be involved with what
you're about that's it I don't want mine
how is that I don't want my girlfriend
to do this and that and that and I don't
want to be with someone that does this
and that what do you know about all
women what the [__] did you just say
that's it right I will dress however I
want if I'm with you or without you
nobody will tell me how to dress that is
the point but this is what we're talking
about the thing that they're saying he's
saying is you can dress that way with me
but not but not without me so why is
that why is why do you hold that belief
it's not oh I don't want you to dress
this way it makes me uncomfortable it's
you can dress this way with me but not
with other people
Abba and reach [__] god dude all
right Ethan slime
I actually like I would reach I've been
reached I've been reached a hobo Springs
I've heard a bunch of these things not
bad they're not bad the better ones is
Apple and Peach I gotta give that out
that's a good one too uh that's good I
I've been reach out showing a ton of
cleavage or wearing as little clothing
as possible wearing political clothing
is possible okay so it's cool when
they're with you because but if they go
out looking like that it's not okay and
I mean no I would say even okay but
that's literally what you said in the
video then he corrected himself and then
when he came on the Pod and he expanded
he said you're walking it back or maybe
in a long format there's maybe more
opportunity for nuance there not because
it makes me uncomfortable I just think
it's unsightly to be that desperate for
attention yeah I think it's gonna be
coming me partially it's the same thing
with women posing clear straps every
year I don't give a [__] if women want
to do that but if we together and you
pose on third shots like who are you
trying again it's like I really need to
see the outfit we're talking about
because I feel like their definition or
at least Sebastian's definition of
provocative is not really provocative
whose attention you trying to Garner if
you're in a committed relationship with
somebody and you constantly gonna try to
post things to get random attention from
random people I'm like why am I
why are you thirsting for other people's
validation like that this is the same
thing for dudes again that wasn't even
the argument it was he said you can
dress that way with me but not with
other people then he corrected himself
so we can move on but in this video you
say dress sexy when you're with me but
not when you're not with me women can
dress sexy and not provocatively you can
dress sexy and can we please without
showing like because the fact at this
point we're so removed from yeah where
the conversation started can we show
what he said yeah they didn't I don't
know I don't think they showed the whole
thing we literally showed that Tick Tock
that's how the video starts
here's one about what girls can't wear
so let's see let's take a look at this
well it depends I mean fashion is so
broad
but these [__] just making it
up as they go
they got they got seven people on their
team
and all of them too [__] to be like
actually Ethan they played it in the
first like two seconds
what do you want me to do man it's just
being preached on this operation and
y'all send this video up we react to
them in life they got seven people they
can't stop also making false allegations
doxing people or memorizing the clip
that they watched like 30 seconds ago
Ethan mental decline because the
retardation on screen right now is
impressive it's not insecurity either
it's it's not insecurity it's just I
don't want I don't like that I don't
want it like let's follow this no it's
not because you're you're basically no
it's not you're do you want would you
want your wife out there okay you want
your wife out there dress like a hoe
see like what does that mean rest like a
hoe
like provocative uh I mean guys come on
well the definition of a hoe I guess is
I'm not quite sure what that means
but you're gonna answer my question
would you would you want her out there
dressing or wearing as minimal clothing
as possible out in a club
what I want my well hold on hold on no
answer the question okay well let me
show you this yesterday okay well hold
on I don't know what he means I need to
know what does dressing like a home mean
to him you know what he said he he
already said this this is the part where
you're being slimy okay he said with
minimal clothing
says what that [__] means so he doesn't
want his partner engaged in that kind of
behavior yeah that's fine
but do you know why she's posting I mean
that's that's you and your wife your
relationship
I'm trying to understand your point
would you do you think she's dressed
like a hoe right now and you can say yes
it's fine
yeah I wouldn't want her posting I
wouldn't want my girlfriend posting
pictures because that's a preference
from insecurity right yeah because it
makes you feel insecure even that's not
an argument you can't just repeat the
same thing and then think it's gonna be
true if you keep saying
it's 100 a preference from insecure yeah
sorry it is it is an argument actually
and you can just say no but you're wrong
so okay the attention
foreign
first of all it's not like she's she's
not dressed like a
star
okay she's wearing less than a bikini
top or more than what a bikini top would
show okay this is actually really
interesting even it says what's wrong
with a porn star yeah you noticed it why
can't my girl dress just as scandily as
a prime star what's the issue with that
what's wrong with that if I'm saying
your ideology my girl she feels
empowered when she wears next to nothing
I should be yeah what's the problem with
that so you see Ethan isn't in a
different category he has just a
different degree in regards to his
tolerance for how his wife dresses
that's your life and listen that's fine
and someone else slide might be like I
love it when my girl wears literally
nothing
right and that's their life and someone
else's line is I don't want my girl
dressed in a in a sports bra walking
outside and that's their line you guys
are shaming people just because on the
Spectrum they're a little bit left of
you or right of you right I will dress
however I want if I'm with you or
without you
nobody will tell me how to dress that is
the point the relationship you can't
post it's your partner in a relationship
there's certain things you can't post
okay so okay I agree I don't want ELO
posting a picture of her [__] on uh
Instagram right me neither but she do
but you remember what I said before bro
it's a spectrum yeah this [__]
on the same Spectrum there's there's
another man out there who's got a girl
who's posting everything on Twitter she
got her full news and she getting real
and that's their relationship is fine
it's fine would you be controlling if
you told your girl she can't post that
kind of stuff online would you
because you'd be insecure then right and
what would you do if she decided to you
would probably leave her because I
assume you're a reasonable person you're
like I don't want to be with somebody
who's posting that kind of content and
that's okay yeah but we're not talking
that's not the conversation
I said that before we don't disagree the
thing is I believe that us three on this
point we agree me neither but that's I
was trying to gauge where his definition
of hoe is right he thought Ela was
dressed too provocatively
that is [__] ridiculous very strong
argument Ethan why is that ridiculous
why isn't butthole provocative right
like for you a sports bra is not
provocative I know most people out there
would say people would say that's
provocative no you didn't make an
argument for why your line is more
reasonable you just said the other
line's ridiculous he has no way of
determining what's too far for him or
why it is he's just made an arbitrary
line which is okay
but he does it everyone else for their
arbitrary lines good no you know what
Ethan is I'm gonna tell you what it is
all right Ethan is everybody that's on
the road driving
and no matter what the speed limit is
you're the gauge anybody that's slower
than you is a slow [__] yeah
everybody that goes faster than you no
matter what speed you're going yeah
either
fast crazy [__] so it doesn't
matter if you're doing the limit if
someone's going fast you're like that
guy's crazy but people that are doing
one 41 20 people are going
that are going faster than that or crazy
that's you yeah that's what you are true
well to me I don't want to control I
want my my wife Ila to be as powerful
and confident as she wants to be I'm not
threatened if it makes you feel
confident and Powerful to post search
traps on social media it's not a thirst
strap dude again it's not it's just not
a third strap if you want to call it
that sure or whatever yeah it doesn't
meet my definition of a thirst trap like
not at all see how we can okay I can see
how we can if you need internet
validation for you to feel powerful and
confident in my opinion that's not much
power and confidence my personal opinion
if you have to Post online and have a
bunch of strangers tell you you're
amazing for you to feel power and
confident I don't know to me that seems
a little bit okay your whole video is to
make you feel confident
to me your whole video is a little sus
yeah
yeah she bad
you
know you wanted to feel
at least I I don't even think what I
said was ridiculous and you need to be
online posting photos of yourself to
feel powerful and confident I think that
your self-confidence and your
self-esteem is built on on Sand all
right what are my thoughts
go watch the video see if you guys feel
differently than that clip that he
posted which is 14 minutes long you guys
could go watch it it was interesting to
watch I will say there's one thing that
they covered in that interview that we
didn't cover uh that I think we missed
because preach was done with the video
but at one point they post up some of
his Instagram photos
and they showcase him being a hypocrite
because he's posting thirst traps now
I'm gonna say this extra part if I meet
a girl she's some kind of only fans
model or she loves posting thrift shops
every day we get in a relationship and
then I expect her to change like
obviously that's wrong on me like you
found her one way while you demanding
change all of a sudden right uh and also
I wouldn't even demand change like I've
never had this issue because I've never
dated people who engaged that kind of
behavior so I see a cardi B type and I'm
like that's not for me I just keep it
pushing I don't go and judge her I don't
want to say nothing I just I don't want
to date that yeah now that's like the
boundary of the relationship this brings
the the sanctity of the intimate
relationship I want to have with my wife
the heart of the conversation is
completely removed I'm gonna just split
here
different types of girls who have
different ideas of what they want to do
like just don't seek out a girl who's
who wants to post [__] like that don't
condemn girls who do like what the [__]
just let them do what they want let your
girlfriend do what she wants and if you
have a problem with her specifically
talk to her about it you know what's so
weird you know what's so weird what we
agree
everything she said we agree yeah
so this whole thing it's a nothing
sandwich pointless it's just
disappointing to see this stuff but it's
not unexpected because this is what I
expect from the h3h3 band the same
people who falsely accuse other people
or docks people for fun like this is
what the kind of stuff that they do
wrong like you talk about these guys are
such cowards like bro you were doxing
people you should be banned on this
platform did you forget that
looks a random person online for no
reason
then you sat there afterwards and
brought this false accuser against
friendship fit just because you hate
them like how you gonna call me a scum
and a coward with some [__] in a
trash bag is telling me I smell funky
like [__] so let us know what you guys
think because I don't know I was very
unimpressed anything else you want to
say
carry on all right let us know what you
guys think in the comments below